so so we're talking about how we can't
you know there's nothing to do so our
birthday this year
because today is wednesday august 26 my
actual birthday yesterday was giannis
birthday
and we're just like this is what we do
now the birthday is kind of just to be
with you the fans because
everything else is freaking close every
year we just have a birthday episode
because our birthdays are so close
together this is our
combined 40th birthday right um
what are we gonna do for it this year
during the pandemic we got to figure
something out what do you want to do
um you want to have a baby cue and i i i
we'll just call it a baby cue because
you know baby
we'll do a baby we could do that or um
you want to hang out with um
venetia's perea in central park and talk
about social justice issues
we could do yeah we could do that why
don't we just or we could just
carry stuff or carry briefcases of
equipment with binky yeah we could do
that yeah
or why yeah or why don't we just
celebrate kamala harris
you know what i i didn't realize how
selfish we were being
yeah this is a historic time for this
country right where an indian
african-american or whatever her father
no she's after me
have jamaican but that makes her an
african-american yeah whatever
her dad's her dad is indian and her mom
is jamaica uh dad is jamaica her mom is
indian
so therefore she is the first
african-american vice presidential
candidate
that's just the country we live in it's
i'm not i'm just saying what it is
it is what it is but um we are we being
selfish by celebrating our birthdays on
such a historic occasion
where really this episode should be
about should we give our birthdays to
black people yeah
yeah i forgot the kid trevor wallace
yeah was on the gramercy theater show
and he sold out two shows
and it's just yeah he just trevor
wallace just looks like me if i got
corona
because look at look at look at what we
did though yeah and that was the first
time we worked with binky that's what it
is there's zach isis remember zach isis
yeah remember zach i mean we've come a
long way i mean look at that crowd
it's unbelievable and i think that i
shouldn't have been wearing that sweater
it was too small for me but who cares
greek stuff it doesn't matter look how
jacked i was though i was working out
then there was gyms open
i was a real strong kid at that moment
yeah i mean i was a kid that like
if you had a snapping right you could
put me down but if i got a hold of you
yeah i'm definitely gonna bite it's
gonna just bite if i get close i'll bite
and i don't know why i decided to wear
shoes that night
yeah but i wanted to be a grown-up was
like almost dead when this happened i
remember the show was
i remember the show was at midnight and
i almost passed out because it was two
i was too sleepy and that girl comes to
every show yeah um
yeah i mean yeah happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
make sure you rate review us subscribe
uh turn on your notifications get jiggy
with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]